The joe rogan experience.
My daughter Loves Bible stories.
Really?
I'm an atheist.
You say once upon a time before you tell them,
oh,
I know.
She knows that stories.
Okay,
yeah.
We call him the big invisible guy,
and you go old school,
Old Testament,
or do you go,
we'd do the whole thing.
Oh yeah.
I've told her the story of,
you know,
I'm the guy who's going to kill his son because the big invisible guy,
I say,
making them in an ice cream,
like baking a pie with whipped cream because you know it's,
that's why you surfing.
I don't have a knife to the throat.
I mean,
she's,
she was four,
but she loves the big invisible guy stories.
She loves the Noah one.
She loves the Adam and Eve one with the snake and the apple.
It's all,
I mean,
these stories that they've stood the test of time.
There's really some of the best stories around who was going to kill his,
his son was Cain and Abel.
Now Cain and Abel,
where the son of Adam and eve,
they were brothers and they killed each other.
Right.
I said,
Isaac and Abraham,
Isaac and I go know,
can we have a weapon?
Abraham Abraham was so,
and God is asking him to kill us on for him.
Yeah.
You know,
as I love test.
Yeah.
Just because you know,
that's how,
you know,
if someone really loves you,
like,
you know,
this is why,
you give this,
um,
you give this to your,
to your wife,
you know,
like I would,
I would murder our offspring for you.
And that's the hallmark card that really helps your wife understand how much you
love her.
I'm just an ex boyfriend.
I'm earning export,
export from the beat you up.
I'll murder him.
And so,
but,
and I'm trying to tell the stories in a neutral way,
right?
Like it's like,
again,
I had my opinions on all these stories and all that,
but she really likes the stories and she's a huge fan of Lucifer.
Whoa.
I mean,
Lucifer is the guy,
he is like her superhero,
you know,
like he is her mighty morphin power rangers.
She thinks he is just the coolest cause he's always standing up to big invisible
guy.
Right.
And,
um,
because for her prayer is,
you know,
everyone's standing around and say,
Oh,
you the best.
Oh you're the best.
Oh you're the greatest.
I love you so much.
Oh you're the best.
You know.
And so,
you know,
Lucifer gets kind of tired of that and leads the rebellion and all that.
Cause you know,
I said,
you know,
just keep saying it.
And she said,
I'm getting tired of it.
It's like,
no,
I keep saying it because it's an eternity of saying that to the gate.
Right?
And she's like,
Oh man,
I'm really tired.
I want to sit down.
It's like now you know how Lucifer out of it.
Anyway,
so she's got this great,
she's just great song,
which goes basically,
Lucifer was raw hide.
Lucifer was right.
You know,
why the songs,
and I'm just waiting.
Cause you know,
in Canada there's some homeschooling,
which is kind of and schooling what we were doing,
but a lot of them are,
are Christians,
right?
So we're going to at some point be around a bunch of Christian kids and she's
going to break into this song.
And I'm looking forward to that moment of,
I've tried to explain that,
uh,
maybe she's referring to a Beatles song.
I don't know how I completely bailed on her at that point.
I don't know where she gets us.
Well,
the real issue is you're going to have to mingle with those Christian parents.
The real issue when you have children,
uh,
besides raising the children,
which is of course the primary one,
teaching them and everything is dealing with these other parents and seeing
it's,
it's really weird when I see people with their kids,
you know,
see how little they interact with their kids,
see how like non appreciative they are of their kids,
how they're always distracted or the ring of cell phones around the playground,
you know,
like it to throw your cell phone,
go play,
go into stupid Mcdonald's tubes and go play with your kids.
I know a woman who's a psychologist and she picks up her kid and she's on her
phone while she's picking the kid up,
the kid trying to talk to her about school and she's like,
uh Huh.
Uh Huh.
And she's texting.
It's,
you know,
I mean you just,
the kid was gone for five hours and when you pick them up you're texting.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
so,
it's so attractive to us though.
So easy to do.
It's so easy to ignore.
We get so used to,
you know,
the kid being around and we get so used to our own free time.
Oh my daughter's really good at that.
Sorry to drive it.
She's great.
Cause you know,
like I'm trying to teach your eye contact,
right?
Because you know,
when she's a kid,
you know,
I don't know if they can't focus when they look at you,
but that tell stories like they're just watching the biggest disco light show on
the planet and you're just like some leaf or something.
Right.
And so I tried to remind her,
you know,
eye contact number,
talking,
that kind of stuff.
Right.
So the other day of course,
and I,
you know,
I try,
Oh gel,
you know,
and I,
but every now and then like I get donations,
my whole show is just donations,
right.
No ads or anything.
And so,
you know,
when a donation comes in it's like,
Ooh,
kibble.
You know,
like I'm,
I'm like the rat with the pellet,
you know,
people,
what did they get?
And I got this little kitchen noise that comes in cause I'm for anyway,
so you know,
the kitchen noise come in.
My daughter was telling me something really important for her and all that and,
and yeah,
she's great.
She's like four,
she's like,
Daddy,
I can't act like you're absolutely right.
I'm so sorry.
How rude that was of me.
I apologize.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
it's fascinating to watch their little brains develop,
isn't it?
Then watch the way they interacted each other and how they see the world and
realize like that this is how a person is shaped.
And this is the number one problem that we have as a race is that we don't
respect this process and that we also don't respect this process in strangers,
especially people that we know are fucked.
People in bad neighborhoods,
people in bad circumstances,
people in a abusive families.
We know they're fucked and we don't,
we don't do anything to stop it.
One thing that I keep harping on is that if we have a resource,
whether it's oil or gold bean,
we protect that resource and,
and you know we,
we set up laws and we attach a value to it,
but our number one resource for sure is human beings.
We have created all that you see,
whether it's laptops or buildings or cars,
that's all from a human being.
The best way to ensure that that continues to go on is to have less losers in
the world.
The best way to have less losers is help out kids,
educate kids,
get on the ball with them very early and do something as a society to protect
them primary before we go into wars,
before we go into all this stupid shit that we do to spying on people's fucking
emails and looking into their cell phone record.
Before you do any of that,
how about you protect kids first?
That should be of primary importance and it should be like one of those things
where your kid,
you know,
wants to go out and play.
Like do have you done your homework?
You haven't done your homework,
you can't play.
It's that fucking simple.
You can't have your wars unless you fixed the kids.
Okay.
Well,
and they're,
they're so smart.
And I,
you know,
I was,
the humans had a whole bunch of experts,
a on my show,
uh,
which is who talk about the native intelligence of,
of kids.
Like kids can start doing mathematical reasoning at seven or eight months of
age.
They can start,
do using empathy at 14 months.
And my daughter at the age of,
uh,
a four,
we started playing a game called subjective versus objective.
You know,
like is this something subjective?
Like I like ice cream or is this something objective like ice cream is made from
milk.
And you know,
we'd pointed staff as they subject.
There were objective,
you know,
I liked jazz,
subjective or objective and she's like,
Bang,
rattling them off.
The other day she was saying to me,
dad,
you know,
we've talked a lot.
She's always asking me about the show.
In fact,
I should've been taking notes because she's asked me all about you,
uh,
what's going to be the topic?
And I said,
you know what,
I have no idea.
I know it's gonna be interesting to chat with Joe,
no idea what we're going to talk about.
And that was the best conversation.
Yeah,
yeah.
She's asked all about,
you know,
where you're from and what you do and she's awesome.
They did buy mixed martial arts and all that kind of stuff.
And uh,
um,
and so she's going to ask me all the time and I do some shows on economics and
so we talked a little bit about that,
you know,
get money and all that.
And I diagram stuff out for her to,
and she gets it really.
We've gone through the whole history of the Second World War the other day.
She says,
you know,
my Daddy,
I think I've decided why I want to do,
I think when I get bigger,
I think I just like to work at it.
I want to be the government.
I'd love to be the government because I just,
I want to type whatever I wanted to my bank account.
And I was just like,
wow,
you just nailed the Federal Reserve.
Like right there in a nutshell,
whatever I want into my bank account.
[inaudible] your old logic but perfect.
That is what it is.
They can print their own money.
Yeah.
It's beautiful.
Great system.
Yeah.
No and I and I,
I come out of the sort of libertarian world,
right?
So I mean I'm an anarchist but I come out of the libertarian world and
Libertarians very much as we talked about non aggression principle and so on,
and I've been fighting this,
this battle in the libertarian world and in other worlds as well around,
you know,
things is to me is basic a spanking,
right?
I wasn't sure,
I mean we touched on this,
we
just throw a few stats for the audience who hasn't seen it before.
More than 90% of parents of toddlers say they smacked their child.
Toddlers,
60 61% of moms,
three to five year olds have spank their child.
In the past week.
Boys is spanked a lot more than girls.
Boys are also diagnosed with Adhd,
which is one of the symptoms of spanking a lot more than girls.
Spanking can continue into the adolescent years.
30 to 40% of people in junior high,
kids in junior high.
I still being spanked.
Moms do spank children a lot more than fathers do.
Even controlling for time spent with kids and all of that kind of stuff.
Uh,
economic status doesn't have a huge amount to do with spanking,
but culture does.
So African Americans a do a do a lot more corporate punishment.
Uh,
religious conservative fundamentalists do a lot more corporal punishment and so
on.
And this to me is such a fundamental thing.
I'm very much for philosophy that you can do philosophy,
that you can act on values that you can do.
Yeah,
I don't like the Federal Reserve.
I think central banking is a monstrous cancer in the eyeball of society,
but I can't really do much about it other than rant and rave about it.
But we kept,
what we can do is,
you know,
do some basics like stop hitting kids.
You know,
that to me it's a very fundamental,
and in the libertarian community that's a challenge lot.
A lot of um,
religious conservatives in the libertarian community as you know,
like on the,
on the right or wrong republicans,
there tend to be more religious people on the left,
a secularist less religious people but more socialists and so on.
And it is really tough,
you know,
to just get that basic thing across.
We tell kids not to hit each other and we hit kids and we've all,
I don't know if you out there,
you see bad parenting sometimes when you're out and you act,
you actually,
and I'll usually say something to the parents because I don't mind my,
my Aa,
I think it's the right thing to do.
I don't want my daughter to see me be all about the ethics and then not talk to
people doing something wrong.
But you can see parents hit kids saying don't hit your sister.
And that the fact that they can do that without their heads exploding from this
wormhole contradiction of Pretzel logic is just astounding.
But it is something,
we still have a long way to go in.
I think we're kind of slowly getting there,
but we have a long way to go and just let's not hit kids.
Yeah.
I think how much of the world would change if we didn't do that?
I think we would be virtually unrecognizable as a culture.
I couldn't agree more.
You know,
I read this article recently on my message board.
Uh,
I don't have it in front of me,
so I apologize to whoever posted it,
but it was about a man who got stuck in the financial system of divorce and it
was from his perspective,
he committed suicide,
lit himself on fire.
I started reading his perspective and they came to his house and he had his
initial issue because he slapped his daughter in the mouse so hard that her
mouth was bleeding.
And he did it because she was licking his hand.
She kept licking his hands,
so he slapped her in the mouth til her mouth was,
and then everything I,
I,
I stopped reading right there.
I'm like,
I don't want to know this guy.
I don't,
I,
I'm sad that he was so fucked up that he committed suicide.
But if I saw a guy slap his daughter in the face because she was licking his
hand,
I would have to really suppress my urge to strangle him.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's violence.
That's violence to someone who cannot defend themselves leaf.
Not only that,
not only that,
it's,
it's fundamentally the most fucked up kind of violence because you're doing it
to a developing human being who you allegedly love.
You're teaching them the violence is a part of life by the people that they
respect the most,
and that it can be done to you at any time when you don't agree with whatever
fucking guidelines and rules they've set up,
like licking your hand.
And my daughter was licking my hand.
I'd be laughing my ass off.
I would think.
It's so funny I do that.
I'd smack her in the mouth.
It just fucking insane.
But people,
they fall into this pattern and they don't know.
Don't realize that violence is violence just because you're not going to hurt
the kid that bad.
They're just going to spank him and you think it's no big deal.
Fuck yeah,
it's a big deal because that kid,
it's a horrific situation.
You're doing something that they can't control.
Your holding their arm,
they're moving their body and then this big hand comes in slaps their ass and
they feel pain and they feel confused cause you've acted out against them.
You've not only acted out against him,
you've done it aggressively yelling at slapping and it's a terrible,
it's terrible precedent to set a terrible idea to plant in a child's mind and
it's unnecessary.
It's just not necessary for you to tell me that you can't sit down and reason
with your child and do it with love and the,
yeah,
they're going to freak out and fucking flail.
Sometimes they get mad and yell and that's because they're a fucking child.
You piece of Shit,
you don't smack them.
You know,
you just need someone for being short,
pitting your friends.
It's like hitting your for I don't be,
don't hit anybody man.
Well,
and,
and in particular,
you know,
the moral concentration of like black hearted nastiness,
you hit your wife,
she,
she got to date you.
She got to,
you know,
you had an engagement.
She,
you know,
she,
she chose you and you chose her,
but if you hit your wife,
she at least had to do you get to test drive you shit,
you know,
and then she can leave at anytime.
She's an adult,
she's got shelters,
she's got whatever.
People will help her,
hopefully.
But kids that didn't choose you as parents,
you know,
and they can't leave and they have no options.
And I say this,
my daughter,
you know,
I say,
um,
I know you're not here by choice.
You know,
you didn't choose me as the day I choose to have kids.
I didn't,
you didn't choose me as a dad.
The way I have to parent is I want to parent.
Like,
if my daughter did have a choice of any doubt in the world that she would choose
me like,
and so I imagine these all day long.
Absolutely.
And,
and,
and what about feedback?
You know,
and I go to my local pizza joint half the time I have to fill out.
Why don't they give me this comment card to fill out,
you know,
how did you like the pizza?
You know,
what's good for you?
Was it bad for you?
You know,
they wanna know they wanna have good pizza and how many times the parents do
that with their kids say,
how am I doing,
you know,
how's your experience of my parenting?
You know,
what's more important slice of pizza or your relationship with your offspring.
ask them how you're doing.
How could they have been better?
What did I do that,
that you liked?
What did I do that you didn't like?
And all that.
Get that kind of feedback.
I don't know.
It's just weird that we don't even think of doing that.
Well,
I think your perspective is very unique in the fact that you are a stay at home
dad and you do have the resources to be able to do that.
It's,
it's,
it's really hard for a lot of people.
And that's while you were talking about before,
that number's pretty crazy.
The 20 minutes a week.
I didn't know that it was that low,
but honestly,
not shocked.
I don't have a regular life,
but I've dabbled in regular life,
you know,
I've had like jobs that take me away for a long period of time during the day
and I could only imagine what kind of energy you have to devote to a kid.
If the mother,
both the mother and the father both leave the house all day long,
work an eight hour day and then come home.
How much is left?
There's not even much time the kid's going to be awake.
Yeah.
How much energy do you have left?
How much focus or you're putting on that kid during the day
and,
and we have this,
I'll get a couple more stats.
Um,
we have this idea that the moms have to be there and the dads can be there.
But a study conducted by Dr. Kyle Pruitt found that infants between seven and 30
months respond more favorably to being picked up by their fathers.
He also found a father's parenting style is beneficial for a child's physical,
cognitive and emotional and behavioral development.
Mothers tend to reassure toddlers when they become frustrated while fathers
encouraged them to manage their frustration.
And my daughter's like this,
so she's learning to do all these things and,
and most of her friends are older cause you know,
we're not the youngest on the block.
And so a lot of her friends can do stuff better than she can.
She gets frustrated and me helping her talk it through that frustration and
reminding her that I didn't know how to do this stuff and you know,
she's trying to do racket sports and I remember took me years to become good at
racket sports.
So,
uh,
so that's important for,
for kids as well.
I mean,
it's really important to remember,
you know,
the,
the mom and the kid,
they used to be the same freaking person,
you know,
like she grew her,
they were like this,
it's like my arm,
you know,
it's not like a separate thing.
Whereas they had to have a little bit more objectivity around that.
A longer term study that this guy did to prove that a father's active
involvement with his kids from birth to adolescence promotes greater emotional
balance,
stronger curiosity,
a stronger sense of self assurance,
additional studies during the first five years of a child's life.
The father's role is more influential than the mothers in how the child learns
to manage his or her body,
navigate social,
social,
social circumstances in play.
And the last one is this.
The 1996 study that I was referring to before by Mcgill University.
Uh,
the single most important childhood factor in developing empathy is paternal
involvement in childcare.
The study further concluded that children who spend time alone binding but the
children more than twice per week brought up the most compassionate adults.
Um,
so
how do they measure that?
How's that quantifiable?
Um,
it seems like a weird,
all of those statistics seemed very odd.
It's like how do you know what caused the person to have more empathy?
How do you know what caused the person to be able to move better?
And I mean,
how do you,
how do you work
well,
what they proved that,
again,
it's sort of a many to many relationships.
So they asked the father is,
you know,
how often were you involved in,
maybe they even measured them if it's sort of a life study and then they
measured the compassion and then they measure a whole bunch of other things.
And if the other things don't change the compassion measure,
but then the parental involvement is what moves the needle,
then they assume that that's close to causal.
But isn't the issue also the parental involvement?
Like say if a father is involved a lot in the kid's life,
he's also probably likely involved in the relationship with the wife and maybe
their wife would be more happy.
The father and the wife would be more happy and because of that they would both
be better parents.
So it could,
it might not just be that the impact of having a man around does all these
things and creates an empathy.
It might be the impact of having a successful family as well.
Right,
right.
And that certainly is true.
And again,
I didn't run the studies.
I assume that they've tried,
like whenever you questioned this,
always tried to tease it out this way or that way,
and they,
they to try to find that answer.
Um,
but I do think that compassion,
again,
you know,
I mean,
you,
your marriage,
you've got,
you've got kids floating around and all that and floating,
but there,
but they were floating at one point and then they came out through the magic
chamber.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I think,
you know,
I mean,
my wife's skills as a parent are fantastic and,
um,
but,
but there are some differences between us,
you know,
and I don't know whether it's biological or whether it's just the way we were
raised or whatever,
but,
uh,
you know,
I encourage more risk taking a,
I'm,
I encourage,
you know,
if you fall off the horse,
get back up and again,
kind of stuff.
And I think that's just sort of,
kind of a natural kind of difference.
And,
um,
I'm also more encouraging of,
you know,
my daughter is like crazy frenzy.
I keep thinking she's going to go up to someone sometimes an unfriendly world,
like a cheese up to a greater,
you know,
we're just kind of get shredded because,
we go places and she just goes up to kids and says,
hi,
would you like to be friends?
And I was cool.
Fantastic.
You know,
the old people up a little,
you know,
oh,
I love it.
Wouldn't that be,
everybody was on ecstasy.
That's how we would interact with each other.
Okay.